by la parole était nicolas tchernobyl à
écouter regarder avec les médias ce qui
s'était passé a été hospitalisé puis
admis en soins intensifs pendant la
première vague ça a été un cas très très
grave mais vous ne souhaitez pas pour
autant vous faire vacciner pour le
moment à moins que l'on ne trouve que
c'est efficace et sans danger pour la
santé mais on en a parlé quand même
pendant la soirée il ya des tests qui
sont faits à grande échelle dont il est
de votre micro marche par essayer
montant des dons oui on vous entend très
bien vous entend pas alors donc à des
tests ont été faits l'efficacité moi je
suis 90% pour parler déjà je vous
explique un petit peu mon parcours moi
j'ai pas d'antécédents médicaux j'ai
jamais trop menaçante et j'en ans est
sorti de haut niveau une hygiène de vie
irréprochable
j'ai eu ce virus en mars vous avez quel
âge j'ai 39 ans joueur de rugby après
les jours parce que ce jour là non mais
comme l'annoncé ce jour de mon
anniversaire j'ai passé mon anniversaire
l'hôpital entre quatre murs tout seul et
dans mon histoire
j'ai fini en réanimation j'ai frôlé la
mort à ça bon aujourd'hui quand vous
parlez de touche du virus je pense que
je suis quelqu'un qui peut très bien en
parler quand on parle de vaccins qu'on
en parle tous ces choses à moi je pense
que les gens le fond du problème qui
aujourd'hui c'est la communication parce
qu'il ya un problème de communication de
pl oui bah moi pourquoi je suis
contrarié c'est pas je suis contre le
vaccin mois si demain à 100% qu'on me
dise et de chroniqueurs si on me prouve
que j'aurais pas d'effets secondaires
dans dix quinze ans que j'aurais pas
problème est que je peux réparé le
rattraper pas contaminer des gens là
bref moi j'ai une grand mère qui à 80
ans qui me dit que demain je fais
vacciner que je vais pas là contaminés
et je peux le savoir moi quand j'ai eu
mon virus
si je vous dis les symptômes qui je veux
on n'a jamais parlé sur les aucun
plateau télé et aucun signalement a été
fait sur ses premiers effets secondaires
des effets que j'ai au débat je les ai
qui me brûlait tous les effets qu'on
parle à la télé je n'ai jamais eu mais
j'étais dans un état je ne pouvais plus
marcher et que je suis on voit l'état
dans lequel vous êtes je pouvais plus
marcher
c'est ma femme j'ai appelé en deux en
trois nuits en deux nuits on appelait
huit fois le ca mur vous êtes comme a
répondu vous êtes en train stressé
monsieur vous inquiétez par bourdieu
vous avez rêvé juste une grippette voilà
lorsqu'on mardi en deux nuits j'ai
peut-être c'était débordés je les
comprends mais moi j'ai frôlé la mort
quand j'ai frôlé la mort g de garin j'ai
une femme je peux pas me permettre de
demain de prendre un risque et de meuron
autres choper peut-être ce virus que
j'ai même pas le savoir et peut-être
contaminés et faire mourir des gens
c'est ça qui est important il faut
savoir et c'est la communication qui est
pas bonne depuis le départ et depuis des
années depuis qu'on a commencé il ya
plein de choses qui ont été dites
il ya beaucoup de gens qui dit plein de
choses fait une connerie mais rien de
concret et quelles questions vous soir
l'aviation
aujourd'hui j'ai alors c'est quand on
voit le virus qui a muté en angleterre
il y a eu je sais pas combien de
vacciner plus d'un million de personnes
vaccinées
expliquez-moi pourquoi aujourd'hui leurs
vivres seront par de belles et que ces
gens ont été vaccinées une grosse partie
comme des gens étaient vaccinés comment
vous l'expliquez pas beaucoup les lions
viennent de se vacciner mal pas beaucoup
je respecte infiniment votre souffrance
j'ai une copine moi j'ai eu la chance
d'avoir une forme d une version faible
du virus donc je ne me comparerais pas
ce que j'ai vécu au martyre que vous
semblez avoir traversé en revanche si
vous me permettez sur un plan plus
philosophique je suis effaré par ce que
vous êtes en train de dire comment est
ce que vous pouvez considérer que la vie
doit être une garantie zéro risque sur
30 ans qui viennent je veux dire on est
depuis 1950 dans des sociétés d'enfants
gâtés en occident on perd toute
sensation de pouvoir à tout moment
défaillir avoir des douleurs avoir des
deuils rencontré la mort sur son
parcours et peut-être même perdre la
sienne
ce qui n'est jamais agréable mais ça
s'appelle l'existence humaine et dans le
fait d'exister monsieur il ya le fait de
se projeter en avant
et quand on se projette en avant il ya
le fait évidemment de s'écraser contre
quelque chose qui peut être une tragédie
qui peut être une maladie qui peut être
un accident et je suis désolé mais moi
je donnerai des millions pour ne pas
avoir en rêve
ce qui est pour vous votre coach est
satisfait d'avoir l'absence de risque
simple absence du risque c'est
simplement la diversion mais je sais que
0 et le 6 et le fil le risque zéro
n'existe pas ça je suis conscient mais
talent j'ai écouté j'ai rôles et un truc
qui m'a interpellé
vous avez bien dit quelque chose red
hill ce virus on ne le connaît pas ouais
on ne le connaît pas et c'est sûr qu'on
ne connaît pas et vous avez dit une
chose aussi le vaccin va peut-être être
bon pour six mois
moi je vous donne mon cas alors on
parlait de d'anticorps j'ai moins mon
virus 16 mars en septembre je n'ai plus
d'anticorps à tout moment je peux leur
chope et qui me dit aujourd'hui je veux
pas leur chope et de même manière il y
en a qui l'ont choqué dans même manière
monsieur juste une question vous qui
avez tant souffert et franchement je
vote mais heureusement que vous tendez
de sortie est ce que vous auriez pas
préféré justement être vaccinés pour ne
pas l'avoir 1 est ce que c'est quand
même la sq en travaux je finis sur le
cadenas droit de choisir ce que vous
avez et vous verrez qu'on va nous la
poser rado tonio ou de fer d'antonio
excusez moi vous avez aucun point ne
vous avait pas posé la question sur le
variant anglais mais est ce que le
vaccin qui est actuellement administrée
en france et en angleterre va être et 6
cas sur le variant anglais il y en a un
deuxième c'est le sud africain tient la
barre
est-ce que ça va être efficace je
voulais rebondir c'est ce que disait
penser parce qu'effectivement la seule
la certitude qu'on peut vous apporter là
tout de suite à 95%
c'est le fait de ne pas vous retrouver
dans une chambre d'hospitalisation grâce
au vaccin
je crois que c'est quand même une belle
river vous mentez je veux bien pouvoir
débuter ou vous ne venez pas avancer 95%
s'il vous plaît faites vous n'avez aucun
recul sur ce vaccin ne venez pas annoncé
sa démission démission le député s'il
vous plaît c'est très grave ce que vous
dites mais très très grave et chaude
vaccins et sur 1 95% à l'espace abonné
vous dans le même état vous ne nuit en
rien son résultat des élections